they did the opposition kills Thomas
thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
Prime Minister our prayers go out to
those who capsized in the freezing
Waters of the channel last night it's a
reminder that the criminal gangs running
those routes put the lives of the
desperate at risk and profit from their
misery they must be broken up and
brought to Justice
Mr Speaker tomorrow will be the first
ever Nationwide nurses strike
all the primaries touched to do to stop
that is to open the door and discuss pay
with them if he did the whole country
would Breathe the sight of relief
why won't he no Minister Mr Speaker we
have consistently spoken to all the
unions involved in all the pay disputes
that there are but I am I am glad he's
raised our nurses because they do do
incredible work and it's worth putting
on record it's worth putting on record
what exactly we have done for our nurses
last year last year when the rest last
year when everyone else in the public
sector had a public sector pay freeze
the nurses received a three percent pay
rise
when the RCN asked for more in-work
training we gave every nurse and midwife
a 1 000 pound training budget
when they asked for nurses bursaries we
made sure that every nursing student
received a 5 000 pound Grant that's
because we do work constructively and we
will continue to back our nurses
going on strike it's a badge of Shame
for this government
instead of showing leadership he's
playing games with people's health
and there is a human cost
Alex from Chester has been waiting for a
gallbladder operation for nearly six
months he's in so much pain he's been
off school since then his operation has
already been canceled twice
his mum who I spoke to this morning is
worried sick
when she heard that strikes could be
called off she was massively relieved
she's desperate for the prime minister
to resolve this all he needs to do is
simply meet the nurses Alex's mum is
listening to this she doesn't want to
hear him blaming everybody else she
doesn't want his usual ducking of the
question she's tuned in now because she
wants him to explain what is he going to
do to resolve the nursing Strife
Mr Speaker it's not just Alex there are
millions of others across this country
millions of others millions of others
who will have their health care
disrupted because of the strike Now The
Honorable gentleman says to get round
the table but we all know what that
means Mr Speaker that is just simply a
political formula for avoiding taking a
position on this issue
If he if he thinks if he thinks the
strikes are wrong he should say so
[Applause]
right that pay demands of 19 are met
then he should say so
what what's weak Mr Speaker is he's not
strong enough to stand up to the union
[Applause]
we know it's Christmas but the party's
not started yet come on
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
in 12 hours time there's a nurse's
strike all he needs to do is meet the
nurses his inaction speaks volumes as
ever with this prime minister it's Tory
politics first patient second
we've never seen a nurses strike like
this before
they've been forced into it because the
government has broken the health system
asked anyone in
the end they will
[Music]
thousand vacancies and there's an
obvious solution scrap the non-dom
status and use the money to bring
through the next generation of doctors
and nurses that's what labor would do
why hasn't he got the guts to do it
what's up Mr Speaker we're already
investing billions more in the NHS we're
already hiring thousands more doctors
and nurses but he asked he asked he
asked about backlog he asks about
backlogs in the waiting times in the NHS
and yes what he always fails to
acknowledge is the impact that kovid did
Mr Speaker that's why we're facing
pressures but we do have a plan not just
more money
doctors and nurses new diagnostic
Centers carrying out millions of checks
and scans new surgical hubs delivering
more elective surgery but if we'd
listened to him Mr Speaker the backlog
would still be growing and that's
because we'd still be in lockdown
Mr Speaker he tries to blame everyone
else his Department
his Department commissioned a report
into the NHS which reported on Monday
that report said we've had 10 years of
managed decline it was not covered
responsibility is sitting right there
and the reason he can't choose nurses
over non-doms is because he's too weak
to stand up for tax avoiders
for 12 years they haven't trained enough
doctors and nurses so we have the Absurd
situation of the NHS spending billions
on agency workers to fill the Gap why
should the country have to put up with
money that should be spent treating
patients being wasted plugging gaps
instead
Mr Speaker Let Me Tell The Honorable
gentleman what we are doing we are
actually
[Applause]
pay deal they can't even decide on a
number amongst themselves we're actually
protecting the public they're protecting
their pay masters Mr Speaker
for working people in this country
for working people in this country it's
Labor's Nightmare Before Christmas
yeah
Starbucks there he goes again pretending
everything is fine try telling that to
those on waiting lists or those that
can't afford to pay for a next day GP
appointment after 12 years of Tory
failure winter has arrived for our
public services and we've got a prime
minister who has curled up in a ball and
gone into hibernation
if he can't act on behalf of patients or
nurses or everyone who wants these
strikes called off then surely the whole
country is entitled to ask what is the
point of him and what is the point of
the government he's supposed to be
leading
[Applause]
not having the impact ambulance waiting
times for category one category one
ambulance waiting times in February of
2020 were actually completely On Target
Mr Speaker cobit has has an impact and
that's why that's why that's why as as
the chief executive of the NHS has
acknowledged this government is serious
about its commitment to prioritize the
NHS but Mr Speaker let's just have a
look at the NHS in labor run Wales shall
we
thank you
the worst a e times in the country Mr
Speaker
under the last Labor government we had
Fair pay for nurses and no strikes so I
won't be taking lectures from him about
that
[Applause]
order order Mr Bowie you promised to
behave don't give me a Christmas present
you want one come on
Mr Speaker this is our final pmqs of the
year so I hope you will pop oh really I
hope you will
uh Mr Speaker what I was going to say
was I hope you will pass on all of our
thanks at least on this side to all
those who kept our house and our
democracy working and I want to finish
this year thinking about our friends in
Ukraine as a result of Putin's barbaric
assault on their freedom Millions will
spend Christmas in Sub-Zero temperatures
without heating electricity or hot water
their suffering is unimaginable but
their bravery is awe-inspiring
so will the Prime Minister join me in
saying that whatever other difficulties
and disagreements we have across this
dispatch box
we are and will remain United in our
unwavering support for Ukraine's Freedom
its Liberty and its victory
well Mr Speaker can I join with the
honorable gentleman in thanking and
paying tribute to all the staff of the
house for the Fantastic work that they
do to support all of us and I appreciate
his comments on Ukraine it has been a
point of incredible Unity across this
house and indeed the country something
that we can all be proud of in our
country that we have stood behind
Ukraine at its hour of need and as I
said yesterday this Christmas many
families will be laying an extra place
at their Christmas table and that speaks
to the generosity and compassion of our
nation and long may that continue
[Applause]
[Music]